Iranian proxies have now carried out
over 60 attacks on US forces in Iraq and
Syria since October 17th you just heard
us discuss that and according to reports
Biden's weak response is leading to
frustration inside the Pentagon as laid
out in the pages of the Washington Post
here with reaction Tennessee senator
Marsha Blackburn so 61 attacks Senator
on Americans that's since October 7th
this comes after there were 80 previous
attacks under the Biden Administration
we have three attacks in return seven
terrorists killed the scoreboard seems
to be in the favor of Iran here do we
need a solomani trump style strike to
get the Iranians to back
down well Kaylie we have to have an
effective kinetic response if we're
going to be able to deter this and bear
in mind we have lost that deterrence and
Biden has lost credibility on this issue
and when you start having people in the
Pentagon going to Washington Post and
other outlets and talking about the
dissatisfaction you know that the
president has been given those other
options but we have to remember much of
this dissatisfaction with this
Administration and much of the distrust
that some in the p
have with the Biden Administration goes
back to the Afghanistan withdrawal and
after that debacle we found out much
much later through hearings that the
president had been given options and
what did he say no we're going to go
forward and then he goes out and he
declares it a success when people in the
military knew this was not a success so
we have to reestablish that deterrence
and we we have to have that effective
kinetic response right it was an
extraordinary success and then we know
we lost 13 beautiful Heroes Americans
that's right there at the Abbey Gates
what what a tragedy Afghanistan was
everyone saw that China saw that Russia
saw that sure and Russia took action and
Iran took action but this was a very
revealing moment this was in the
Pentagon press briefing today watch what
was asked and watch the response from
the deputy press secretary is the
Pentagon waiting for a service member to
be killed before taking stronger more
effective action no absolutely not I
mean I I we would never want to see that
we would never want that to be the
outcome of any
attack I mean are you waiting on an
American to be killed that's a that's a
fair question what what are they waiting
on Senator
Blackburn they have no strategy and
they're going to have to have a strategy
these attacks are not going to end until
we come forward with a way and a
strategy and send that message we're not
going to tolerate this and one of the
things that must be done is to handle
Iran and we have in the Senate voted to
see that $6 billion Frozen but we need
sanctions on that oil production Iran
could put a stop to this if they wanted
to but they don't and bear in mind
they're the ones that are funding these
militias whether whether it's the houis
or Hamas or Hezbollah or Isis in Syria
or Iraq they are the funer so they're
keeping this up because they know that
Biden is weak and that Biden is not
going to come after them they know it
because he hasn't done it so you have to
stop these attacks before somebody does
get killed and when you're North of 60
attacks and they're not letting it up
when the houthis have uh put people into
a cargo ship a japanese-owned cargo ship
and taken control of that you see the
escalation that is there and for This
Crew over in the White House to think
that they can appease their way out of
this situation and not have that kinetic
response they're just pipe dreaming it's
not going to happen no it's not going to
happen it's clearly not happening
they're there have been six attacks
since their pin prick strike you know
Senator Blackburn you mentioned
something there about voting to freeze
the $6
billion okay I spoke with Democratic
Congressman Jared moscowitz he led a
bipartisan effort in the house to freeze
the six billion that Biden unleash Jared
moscowitz in partnership with the
Republican Congressman sent a letter to
Tony blinkin saying let's redesignate
the houth who shot down our drone why is
a democratic congressman
in the house Democrats in the Senate
having to push the Democrat
commander-in-chief why is this
happening it is because this
Administration has people that are
friendly to Iran in that Administration
I've been on the floor of the Senate
talking about uh Arian Tatu who is there
in the dod she has a top secret security
clearance she is Chief of Staff to one
of the assistant secretaries there in
DOD and Cale when you have people with
that kind of security clearance that are
pro-iran that have been a part of the
Iran expert initiative Robert Mali was
another one who was in this
Administration very pro- Iran and you
look at uh the participation of others
in this Administration in the first Iran
deal in this latest Iran deal and now
they're going to free up another1
billion dollar for Iran Iran does two
things when they get a dollar they
enrich iranium just short of where it
needs to be for a nuclear weapon and
secondly they put it into terrorism we
know they put a hundred million into
Hamas Hezbollah houthis each
individually we know that they're
funding these other militias we know
that they are their proxies and they're
carrying out these attacks and everyone
is aware of what is happening Iran Hamas
they all say death to America death to
Israel it is a part of what they're
doing is why we go fight this every day
it is why we stand with Israel we have
to stand with Israel and we have to have
an Administration that will show the
world that we will not be deterred in
our support of Israel yeah it's fantasy
foreign policy and it's leading to a lot
of American death and Carnage such a
tragedy Senator Blackburn thank you very
much hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else